what is up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder i'm warren thompson of
course this is my buddy will my best
friend is here from out of town so i
thought he could be in this because he
has no idea who moon knight is whereas i
know a lot about moon knight so i
thought this would be for a pretty cool
trailer reaction marvel studios just
released it let's go ahead and take a
watch
[Music]
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference between my
waking life
and dreams
[Music]
stevie stephen
i can't tell the difference
between my eyes
thank you
i love the creepy plus the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks
[Music]
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark
it must be very difficult
a voice
in your head
[Music]
oh
[Music]
embrace the chaos
[Music]
march 30th
look at that
so i'm super excited for midnight
because one check out raunchy that look
like it's like pretty dark and marvel is
going towards that darker path now for
everyone who've seen the doctor strange
trailer
that's like taking it down that path and
then moon knight's coming in and blade
and a lot of other people coming in
that's just going to be super awesome
but uh this is kind of cool because he
suffers from the mental illness and like
in the comics that's how he is he
doesn't actually know like do i actually
have the powers of this god and he has
multiple different personalities where
he's like
he he's only my driver on one and then
he's like you know a bunch of different
things and that it was funny because
he's mark specter and he's like why did
you call me mark
right it's just kind of like oh they're
really going to explore
kind of
that mental illness side with the sleep
deprivation and stuff like that so this
is going to be pretty cool things would
be like in a really weird way
a refreshing
marvel show even though it's gonna be
like really dark right it's gonna be
like a dark marvel show but i like that
because i like the gritty i want to beat
the crap out of
a
mummy zombie it's a different take yeah
a mummy zombie is one it's what i'm
going with what did you think of that as
so you'd know nothing about it what did
you think how does it look to somebody
who doesn't look at this stuff or
someone who doesn't look at it all the
time and just kind of peruses it it's
going to be awesome that's right the
violence it melts so well i like the
violence but it melds so well with the
story of building up the characters is
it all a dream is he really suffering
from this we don't know but i'm ready to
find out just wakes up with a gun in his
hand and a guy falling off yeah and
stuff like that yeah scary good time
that we're in for but hey let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below i know a lot of
people are really really excited about
this i am i think it's going to be one
of the better disney plus shows
loki's still my top favorite maybe this
will take a number two spot hey maybe
it'll take number one depending on how
good it is but let us know what you
think about it in the comments down
below and expect a breakdown of the
trailer tomorrow see you next time woof